wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
vorsicht die darfst das so stark
auftreten schon gut ich kann allein im
laufe der arzt schaut sich den fuß jetzt
erstmal an
hoffentlich müssen wir nicht lange
warten das glaube ich nicht wir haben ja
einen termin
hallo hallo hallo guten tag haben sie
einen termin ja ich habe angerufen
unser freund nico benz alles hat
schmerzen am fuß der fuß sieht nicht gut
aus haben sie starke schmerzen
es tut weh der arzt schaut sich das
gleich an
er muss den fuß sicher auch röntgen
vielleicht ist ja gebrochen gebrochen
was höchst gebrochen
egal keine sorge das steht ja auch noch
gar nicht fest sie waren noch nie hier
in der praxis oder dann hätte ich gern
ihre versichertenkarte
sie haben doch eine krankenversicherung
danke bitte gehen sie schon mal den
behandlungsraum der arzt ist gleich bei
ok danke
[Musik]